MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR REGULAR
SCHEDULE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE THE CHAIR
RECOGNIZES THE PRESENCE OF A
FELLOW REPUBLICAN MEMBERS SO WE
WILL GET STARTED.
WE NOTICED THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM BUT HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME LIKE A DOVE
WILL BE JOINING US TODAY.
SUBSTITUTING FOR DOCTOR ARAMBULA
WE HAVE FIVE BILLS I CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND HAVING SAID THAT WILL MOVE
IN FILE ORDER AND ALSO ONE OTHER
HOW CAN I AM FILE UNDER ITEM
NUMBER.
ONE AB ONE EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR SO AGAIN
ITEM NUMBER ONE PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR SO WILL THEN JUST GO DOWN
TO AN ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ZERO FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE.
ASSEMBLY WERE SOON WELCOME A AS
AGAIN WE ARE -- ACTING AS
SUBCOMMITTEE DUE TO LACK OF CORN
THIS DOESN'T CHOICE SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES PLEASE FEEL FREE
PRESENT WAIVER READY.
BURKE ALLOWS CANNABIS TESTING
LABORATORIES TO AMEND
CERTIFICATES OF ANALYSIS TO
CORRECT MINOR ERRORS CURRENTLY.
THE THE RULES WAY THAT THEY'RE
CONSTRUCTED ANY AMENDMENT TO THE
CERTIFICATE OF ACCEPTANCE NO
MATTER HOW MINOR REALLY CAN'T BE
ACCEPTED AND WHEN SOMEONE IS
ASKING FOR THE FOR A RETEST.
THOSE STANDARDS ARE REALLY TOO
STRICT TO ALLOW FOR PRODUCT TO
GO OUT ON THE MARKET WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT GIVES THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL THE ABILITY
TO RETHINK THAT A LITTLE BIT AND
MAKE SURE.
THAT IF THERE ARE MINOR ERRORS
THAT THEY CAN BE CORRECTED
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO THROUGH THE
TESTING PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN.
IT'S IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO SOME
OF THE CANNABIS RULES HAVE BEEN
PUT IN PLACE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND CAN A CRAFT I'M
PLEASED TO BE CO SPONSORING THIS
BILL TODAY.
I'M THE INTENT IS TO YOU --
ALLOW TESTING LABS TO CORRECT
NEGLIGIBLE ERRORS -- THERE ARE
COMMON EXAMPLES AND INCLUDING --
REVERSING O. G. WITH GEO --
WE'VE HAD OTHER SITUATIONS WHERE
WE JUST HAD A A MINOR SPELLING
ERROR AND THAT RESULTED IN A
FAILED BATCH SO THIS WOULD --
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF TO ADD THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF NOT HAVING TO FAIL
A BATCH SIMPLY BECAUSE OF A
NEGLIGIBLE ERROR THAT OCCURRED
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
UP.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME INTO MY
FROM NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
MAX WHAT WAS ON BEHALF OF FLOW
COMMON SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
TINO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COULD BE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SUMMER SUN TO WISH TO CLOSE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ONCE
UNIFORM THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
JUST THIS ONCE WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
NOW MOVE ON THEN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOMEONE OR DAILY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES TO BE
LICENSED AS REAL ESTATE BROKERS
RIGHT NOW REAL ESTATE BROKERS
DON'T HAVE THE OPTION OF
BECOMING LLC'S.
OUR STATES REGULATED REAL ESTATE
BROKERS THROUGH THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SINCE THE
NINETEEN FORTIES.
LIMITED LIABILITY COMPANIES DID
NOT EXIST AT THAT TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIA BEGAN LICENSING AND
REGULATING BROKERS.
LLC'S WERE INTRODUCED IN THE
SEVENTIES.
AND OF GRADUALLY EVOLVED INTO
THE VEHICLE OF CHOICE FOR A
NUMBER OF PROFESSIONS.
THIS BILL WILL ADD LLC'S TO THE
LIST OF ELIGIBLE REAL ESTATE
BROKER LICENSEES.
AND PUT REAL ESTATE BROKERS ON
THE SAME FOOTING AS OTHER
PROFESSIONALLY LICENSED GROUPS.
WITH ME TODAY IS MATTHEW
HARGROVE.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
WHO ARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL.
THE REST IS OUR GO UP TO THREE
MINUTES WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME A MATTHEW HARD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY -- QUITE HONESTLY AS
LLC'S PERFORMED IN THE EARLY
NINETIES AND AS THERE IS A LOT
OF CHANGES IN THE LLC LAW
THROUGHOUT THE NINETIES AND IN
THE TWO THOUSANDS.
ARE INDUSTRY SIMPLY MISSED THE
BOAT -- OUR FOLKS DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND HOW OPERATING AS AN
LLC -- AND HAVING YOUR LICENSE
WORKING AS A AS AN LLC INSTEAD
OF A C. CORP WHICH IS OUR ONLY
OPTION RIGHT NOW -- WOULD
BENEFIT THEM IN OVER THE YEARS
THAT HAS BECOME PLAINLY CLEAR
THAT LLC'S ARE THE THE CHOICE
FOR MANY.
COMPANIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL WOULD
MODERNIZE.
OUR INDUSTRY AND ALLOW US TO
FORM AS AN LLC INSTEAD OF JUST
TO SEE CORPORATE WOULD PROVIDE
AN OPTION AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU'LL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
TEAM THAN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM KENNY MEMBERS AT
THIS TIME.
TINO QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SUMMER DAY THAT YOU WISH TO
CLOSE I WILL APPRECIATE A A
POSITIVE VOTE ONCE YOU ESTABLISH
A QUORUM AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SUMMER DANCE
.
AND AND WELL NOW -- IN ABSENCE
OF SEEING ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
HELP PRESENTS A NUMBER OF BILLS
AND PASSED THE GAVEL OVER TO
SOMEONE GLORIA
.
LOOK AT THE SERVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MARK
THIS IS -- IF I MIGHT FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS AB SIX ONE
THREE WISHES ARE CPI FEE
ADJUSTMENT. THREE MEMBERS OF
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO GIVE A
COMMON PROBLEM.
IN THIS COMMITTEE WHERE
REGULATORY BOARDS GO YEARS OR
EVEN DECADES WITHOUT ADJUSTING
THE FEES.
THIS WILL PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
STREAMLINED THIS APPROACH.
WITH ME IS -- THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
SPEAKING IT'S PARK.
THANK YOU CHAIRMN LOW AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIN BONE OF
THE INFORMATION AND PLANNING
OFFICER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY.
LAST MONTH OUR BOARD ADOPTED A
SUPPORT POSITION ON A. B. SIX
ONE THREE WE BELIEVE THAT
CREATING THIS NEW PROCESS TO
ADJUST FEES IN THE MANNERS.
OUTLINED BY THE BILL WILL HELP
OR AGENCY TO MAINTAIN AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF REVENUE WHILE
ACCOMMODATING CHANGING ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OF WITNESSES AND FOR
UNFAIR.
PLEASE COME FOR STATE YOUR NAME.
MERRIMACK IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE IN
A SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION --
WE JUST ACTUALLY WENT THROUGH
THE FEE AMENDMENTS FOR OUR FEE
INCREASE FOR THE DENTAL BOARD TO
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY SO WE
UNDERSTAND.
HOW LONG AND ARDUOUS THE PROCESS
CAN TAKE BUT THE ONE ONE
AMENDMENT WE WOULD LIKE -- TO
PUSH FORWARD IS POTENTIALLY
SUBSTITUTING THE DCA DIRECTOR AS
THE DECISION MAKER OVER -- TO
ENTITY THAT ISN'T FINANCIALLY
INTERESTED IN TO ANY OF THE
LICENSING ENTITIES -- ONE
SUGGESTION WOULD BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE AS IT
MOVES FORWARD HOPEFULLY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IN ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
MOVING OUT OF WITNESSES OR
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
KIM STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPEDIC ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION OUR
CONCERN IS WITH -- LOCKSTEP
RACES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE I
HAVE OTHER AUTHORITY OR
JUSTIFICATION LICENSING FEES FOR
DOCTORS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY QUITE HIGH.
ON ITS OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINETY ONE DOLLARS TO APPLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHT DOLLARS
TO GET A LICENSING FEE THESE ARE
FOLKS NEW DOCTORS HAVE JUST
GOTTEN OUT OF MEDICAL SCHOOL
WITH A TREMENDOUS -- AMOUNT OF
DEBT -- OUR FEES ARE HIGHER THAN
THOSE IN -- OTHER STATES AND YOU
WOULDN'T WANT TO DISCOURAGE
DOCTORS AND FROM COMING TO
PRACTICE HERE PARTICULARLY WITH.
OUR SHORTAGE AND SO WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT ALLOWING --
BLANKET INCREASES WITHOUT THE
SHOWING OF ADDITIONAL NEED OR
JUSTIFICATION -- FOR THOSE
REASONS BUT WE OPPOSE AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU KNOW
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
JUST EXPRESSING THE CONCERN OF
OUR MEMBERS WITH AND JUSTIFIED
FEE INCREASES.
BUT LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR DASCHLE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MR LHOTA TO CLOSE ON THIS BILL.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
SAY AGAIN THIS -- PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STREAMLINED
APPROACH WE DO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY AS YOU KNOW WITH
RESPECT.
TO OUR SENSE OF HEARINGS TO LOOK
FOR THAT TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
JUSTIFY A SUCH INCREASES IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRY BUT WHEN IT
COMES ESTABLISHED.
THANK YOU MR Là THAT WAS EIGHTY
SIX ONE THREE YOU HAVEN'T
NUMEROUS OTHER BILLS YOU CAN
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING WHICH IS WHAT TWENTY LET
ME TAKE YOU VERY MUCH -- AND
THIS IS A FILE I REMEMBER.
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY
FIVE WHICH IS THE BUREAU OF
CAMPUS CONTROL SUNSET -- AND
JUST VERY SIMPLY PUT THIS WOULD
ALLOW SUNSET.
SIMILARLY TO IF THERE WERE OTHER.
ENTITIES THAT WE HAVE UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO PROVIDE THE TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND APPROACH FOR
TRANSPARENCY RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU SO VERY WHEN SUSAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT YES THANK
YOU WE CHECK INS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER JENKINS ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MOVIE OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES
OR SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR
MR LE IN CLOSING COMMENTS THANKS
VERY MUCH CHAUVINIST COMMON
STATUS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU SALUTE WHAT IS YOUR
NEXT BILL YES AND FINALLY --
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
WHICH IS AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT AND THIS IS.
FOR A BILL THAT RESPECTFULLY
HELPS WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS IN
PROVIDING A PREVENTIVE CARE OUT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH NON
OPIATE OPTIONS.
FOR PAIN -- THIS WOULD EMPOWER
PATIENTS FOR FOR AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS.
THESE ADDITIONAL CONCERNS AND
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS A
DOCTOR UPDIKE HOPE PLEASE HERE
BY NOW IF NOT THEN -- WILL
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT.
OUT WHEN AND COM IS ESTABLISHED.
BIGGEST LOSER DR ATTACK SEE A
COUPLE FOLKS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS THAT.
NEITHER WITNESSES AB SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
WITH A MUSICAL INTERLUDE AS YOU
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
TESTER I'M ONLY A DOCTOR OF LAW.
I'VE BEEN ALL TAMARA.
WITH CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DAVID QUACKENBUSH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE
TRADITIONAL MEDICINE ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVING TO
WIN THIS IS OUR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
WARNING TURN MEMBERS MEGAN ALL
RIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND WILL SEE ME DOES NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT WE ARE VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS IT
CURRENTLY MANDATES THAT A
POSITION OFFER A REFERRAL. TO A
SERVICE THAT IS LIKELY NOT
COVERED BY THEIR INSURANCE PLAN.
WE APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE BEEN PART OF THOSE FAR AND
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS IN TRYING TO ENSURE
PATIENTS ARE OFFERED A TREATMENT
PLAN.
THAT IS INCLUSIVE OF ALL
APPROPRIATE OPTIONS FOR PAIN
RELIEF.
WE DO HOWEVER BELIEVE THE SCHOOL
COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED IN A MUCH
MORE MEANINGFUL AND EFFECTIVE
WAY BY ENSURING THAT THESE
ALTERNATIVE SERVICES ARE COVERED
BY INSURANCE THIS WOULD ADD
PROVIDERS OF SERVICES SUCH AS
CHIROPRACTIC AND ACUPUNCTURE. TO
THE INSURANCE NETWORKS AND REFER
ALSO BE POSSIBLE AS A PHYSICIAN
WOULD HAVE A WAY TO KNOW WHO
THEY COULD REFER TO THE PATIENT
TO ENSURE THAT IT WOULD BE
COVERED VISIT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
CONSIDERATION OF OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
OPPOSITION.
SEE NUMBER THERE'S THE COMMITTEE
IN COMMITTEE MEMBER COME
QUESTIONS STRONG.
SO I WANT TO JUST AS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS WHOLE FOR OUR
CAUCUS HAS -- OUR COMMITTEE HAS
A NON ON I WILL BE SUPPORTING A
BILL TODAY I ACTUALLY --
PERSONALLY -- I HAVE I HAVE A
BOLD DISK AND THEY WANTED TO DO
SURGERY AND BY DOING PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND AND ACUPUNCTURE
THOSE THINGS I WAS ABLE TO STAVE
OFF THAT SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS BILL FOR TO BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR -- THIS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU.
M..
I I I SYMPATHIZE WITH MISS
DOLLARS REBELDES DESK BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO'S ALSO BEEN AND IT
IN AND HAD A LOT OF TIME IN
DOCTOR'S OFFICES WITH -- WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS -- IN HAVE HAD TO
TRAVERSE THE MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
LEVELS OF INSURANCE AND WHAT'S
COVERED AND WHAT'S NOT COVERED.
I CAN ALSO SPEAK AS A FAMILY
MEMBER WHO WOULD CARE GIVER --
WHO'S HAD TO TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
AND SO I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT IT BEING THAT A REFERRAL
MUST BE OFFERED -- IN IT KIND OF
FEELS LIKE IF YOU OFFER PEOPLE A
PLETHORA OF THIS IS THIS IS
ABOUT THE ISSUES AND LET A
PATIENT MAKE THEIR OWN DECISION.
BECAUSE I THINK OFFERING THAT
REFERRAL TO SOMETHING THAT THEY
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE IS
PROBLEMATIC SO I WOULD JUST ASK
YOU TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THIS
GOING FORWARD.
NOT EVERYTHING IS COVERED AND
NOT ALL THINGS ARE EQUAL IN THE
WORLD OF INSURANCE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
CENA REQUEST MISTER LO JACK
CLOSE YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS AND APPRECIATING
KNOWLEDGE THE SIMILAR TYPE OF
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
AND RESPECT FAST FIVE OAKLAND.
COR MRS SOUTHWEST [inaudible]
BIGGEST.
RIGHT TO IT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOT MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
NINETY BY THIS AGUIAR-CURRY.
IT'S A GREAT GREAT THIS IS AGAIN
SB SIX NINETY THIS DOESN'T CHOI
A SUPPORT SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I AUTHORED AB FOR A
ONE WHICH AUTHORIZED THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF PHARMACY TO
ISSUE REMOTE.
DISPENSING PHARMACY LICENSES FOR
SPECIFICALLY TO CONNECT A
LICENSED PHARMACIST TO PATIENTS
IT MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS
USING TELEPHONE MISSY TECHNOLOGY.
ALTHOUGH HOWEVER ALTHOUGH FOR AB
FOR ONE IS NO LAW THERE'S NOT
BEEN ANY LICENSES ISSUED.
AND THEREFORE TELL PHARMACY IS
STILL NOT READ A REALITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS BECAUSE WHEN THE LAW WAS
DEVELOPED THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
WAS TASKED WITH DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS TO SET THE REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL TRAINING NECESSARY.
FOR A PHARMACY TECHNICIAN TO
WORK AT A REMOTE DESCENT
DISPENSING SITE. TO DATE THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS TO THESE
REGULATIONS HAS STALLED.
AND COULD TAKE ANOTHER TWO YEARS
OR MORE.
INSTEAD SIX NINETY CODIFIES THE
ADDITIONAL QUALIFICATIONS FOR
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO WORK IN A REMOTE
DISPENSING PHARMACY WHICH WILL
ALLOW THESE FACILITIES AS FAR
THESE FACILITIES FINALLY BE
BECOME LICENSE.
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL COMES
DIRECTLY FROM THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY'S DRAFT REGULATIONS ON
THIS ISSUE.
SB SIX NINETY WILL PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVED
PATIENT EDUCATION INCREASE
MEDICATION ADHERENCE AND BETTER
ALL OVER HELD UP BETTER OVERALL
HEALTH OUTCOMES IN AREAS OF THE
STATE WITHOUT ACCESS TO A
PHARMACY.
I AM C. JOHNSON WITH ME IN HERE
ON SUPPORT OF FROM A CARDINAL
HEALTH I AM THREE AYE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHERRY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MISSY JOHNSON YOU'LL
SUMMER EXCIMER HERE ON BEHALF OF
CARDINAL HEALTH WE LIKE TO THINK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR HER
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE.
AND FOR HER COMMITMENT TO MAKING
SURE THAT TELEPHONE MISSY IS
FULLY IMPLEMENTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
CARDINAL HEALTH IS ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S LARGEST OF WHOLESALE
SUPPLIERS THAT SUPPLIES
HOSPITALS MEDICAL FACILITIES
PHARMACIES DENTAL OFFICES
PHYSICIAN OFFICES WITH ALL THE
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
PHARMACEUTICALS THEY NEED TO
OPERATE.
WE ALSO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES TO INDEPENDENT PHARMACY
SO THAT THEY CAN EXPAND AND GROW
THE VIABILITY OF THEIR
BUSINESSES AND TELL THE PHARMACY
IS ONE OF THOSE.
OPTIONS THAT WE PROVIDE -- THIS
BILL WILL HELP REALIZE THE GOALS
OF AB FOR A ONE BY TAKING THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS DEVELOPED BY
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY OVER A
YEAR AGO.
AND PLACING NOT IN STATUTE THIS
BILL SEEKS TO EXPEDITE NOT
CIRCUMVENT THE PROCESS THAT WAS
DUE.
THE PROCESS THAT OCCURRED AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SO THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO TELEPHONES THE
SERVICES AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEE YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS IS
BORN ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOTICES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
BUT SOME OF THE I THANK YOU FOR
BRING THIS FOR I SUPPORTED YOUR
LAST BILL THIS WILL GREATLY HELP
I KNOW YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL AS
MINE -- WE LOST A LOT OF
PHARMACIES AND IN THE LAST --
EIGHT OR NINE YEARS AND THIS
ABILITY TO BE ABLE -- TO DO
TELEMEDICINE THROUGH THAT WOULD
BE GREAT IF PUSH OUT OF LOOK FOR
TO HELP YOU GET THIS BILL ALL
THE WAY THROUGH AND SIGN THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEN NONE A SIMILAR ACT RECORD
YOU WISH TO CLOSE -- JUST SIZE I
ASKED FOR A VOTE AND ITS SUPPORT
OF RURAL COMMUNITIES PRIMARILY
THE FACT THE MATTER IS IS THAT
THIS COULD BE SITTING FOR EVER.
AND I PRIDE MYSELF ON MAKING
SURE WHATEVER WE GO THROUGH THAT
WE IMPLEMENT WHAT WE BUT BILLS
WE HAVE IN THIS IS GOING TO DO
THAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL
VOTE WHEN WE OF HAS STOPPERS
QUORUM WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE SIX SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY SUMMER MEDINA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM THIS HAS --
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER READY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY A PRESENT AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY ONE ALLOWS A LICENSE.
PSYCHOLOGIST TO ACT AS A
SUPERVISOR OF ASSOCIATE MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
ASSOCIATE CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS AND ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL COUNSELORS
WERE PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
RELATED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND EDUCATIONAL AND CLINICAL
SETTINGS.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL ALLOW
A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST AND LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS ASSOCIATES. TO BE
ABLE TO COUNT THE HOURS THEY
PROVIDE.
COUNSELING TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
STORE STUDENTS TOWARD LICENSOR.
WOULD ALSO ALLOW LICENSE
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SOLDIERS ARE
USING BEST PRACTICES WHEN
COUNSELING THEIR STUDENTS.
HERE TO TESTIFY.
IS CHRISTOPHER JONES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
THIS IS JOHN PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHRIS
FOR JOBS AND I'M IN A LICENSE
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGIST -- I
SIT ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
AS THE ONLY PIECE QUESTION IS
THE ONE I THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA FOR OFFERING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR US -- CURRENT
REGULATIONS DO NOT ALLOW ELLIE
PEAS TO PROVIDE.
SUPERVISION TO OTHER BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES ASSOCIATES
OR PROFESSIONAL WHO WERE
PROFESSIONALS BEING HOURS
TOWARDS RELATIONSHIP.
MANY OF THESE TVS ASSOCIATES ON
PORTS BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
WORK IN PRIVATE PRACTICE.
PRIVATE PRACTICES THAT PROVIDE
EDUCATION RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND PRIVATE
PRACTICES HAVE TO EMPLOY OTHER
BBS LICENSEES TO PROVIDE
SUPERVISION FOR THE ASSOCIATES
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY NOT HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE.
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS
THEY RELATE TO EDUCATIONAL
FUNCTIONING IN ONE INSTANCE WE
HAD TO BE B. S. ASSOCIATES WHO
WERE PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO STUDENTS IN A COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION JUVENILE
DETENTION FACILITY.
UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF AN
ALLEY P. THEY BELIEVE THAT THEIR
HOURS WOULD COUNT TOWARDS
LICENSURE BUT WERE DENIED THE
ENTIRE YEARS WORK WHICH WAS
ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED HOURS.
BECAUSE THE SUPERVISION WAS
PROVIDED BY NELLY P. WE'RE
LOOKING TO CHANGE THIS AND ALLOW
ELLIE PEAS TO PROVIDE
SUPERVISION TO OTHER BBS
ASSOCIATES WHEN THEY'RE
PROVIDING SERVICES WITHIN OUR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
IN EDUCATIONAL AND CLINICAL
SETTINGS THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR BBS
ASSOCIATES TO WORK TOWARDS THEIR
NEEDED HOURS FOR LICENSURE.
WITH SUPERVISION PROVIDED BY
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE EXPERTS IN
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING CAM MANSON
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BOARD
OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES ARE PART
WILL BE REVIEWING THIS BILL
FORMALLY AT ITS MAY MEETING BUT
WE'VE HAD VERY PRODUCTIVE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH --
THE ELLIE P. ASSOCIATION AND
WERE WORKING OUT SOME OF THE
FINER DETAILS SO THAT -- WE CAN
EXPAND -- SUPERVISION IN AREAS
THAT ARE MOST NEEDED AND THAT
WOULD BE IN THE SCHOOLS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
KEY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
YES.
I THINK YOU IN EITHER TO THE
AUTHOR OR TO THE TO THE
SUPPORTER.
SO COULD AN LCSW THEN GET ALL OF
THEIR HOURS SUPERVISED BY ELLIE
P..
UNDER THIS BILL KNOW WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO LIMóN IT TO TWELVE
HUNDRED HOURS SO THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT -- ASSOCIATES HAVE A
DIVERSE EXPERIENCE IN DIFFERENT
SETTINGS.
OKAY AND THAT'S BEST LISTED IN
THE BILL.
YES.
ARCTIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME SEE.
NINE SUMMER READY TO DO WAS TO
CLOSE.
BUT WE ASK YOUR I'VE WORKED
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
WILL GET TO THIS BILL ME FOR
STEPS A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE IS WE ARE JUST WAITING ON
TO ADDITIONAL AUTHORS AS WELL AS
ESTABLISHING QUORUM.
US WILL GIVE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MINUTES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
AUTHOR 2% OF THE WAY SO WE'LL
WAIT.
FOR THE COURT TO BE ESTABLISHED
AND THEN THE FORD ACCORDINGLY
[inaudible]
YEAH
OKAY IF YOU CAN KINDLY ESTABLISH
A QUORUM.
LOW HERE BRO BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
EGGMAN FONG.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE CARE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
TING.
OKAY WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
WILL GO ON TO THE FIRST HAS
COMMAND WHICH IS CONSENT
[inaudible]
SO.
GAMERS IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE
SECRETARY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB FOR
NINETY SIX MOTIONS YOU PASS SB
SIX THIRTY MOTIONS TO HOUSE OF
OPERATIONS AB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
MOTIONS DISASTER PREPARATIONS.
AB EIGHT NINE SIX MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY NINE MOTIONS TO PASS LOW.
LOW EYEBROW BLOOM.
BUT MY CHEN CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN
AND I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GORE I GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN -- WHEN I COME WATER DOES?
COMMENTED OF ICE MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
BELIEVE OF THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE NUMBERS WILL GO ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS AB FOUR
FOUR BY SUMMER STONE WE NEED A
MOTION.
MOTION AND SECOND THEIR MEMBERS
THERE ISN'T A SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOUR ZERO FOUR MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS LOW LOW I
BROWN.
BLOOM.
WHEN MY CHEN?
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN-- WHEN I COME WATER DEATH
CONCORD OF AYE MCCARTY?
MEDINA MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
I BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THE MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS
SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY THIS HAS A
HIGH RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES.
IS THERE MOTION.
MOTION AND SECOND FONG.
HE SAID IT WAS A LITTLE. EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN MOTIONS YOU
PASS TO COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DALY AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
WE'RE NOT VOTING GRAYSON
[inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I COME -- DEATH COMMITTED
OF AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL GO ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS AB SIX
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY IN THIS DOES ENJOY
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
IN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB SIX NINETY MOTIONS DO PAST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM.
WHEN I TEN JUNE?
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN AROUND AYE CONGER DOT COM
WE ARE DEADLINE MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THERE'S WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THEN MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH IS AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND THIS YOUR
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
KIDS IN MOTION AND A SECOND
TWENTY SIX THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS FLOW I'VE
LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM.
WHEN MY CHEN?
YOU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
AND I FONG FUNG AYE GIPSON. FOR
I GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I CONCORD US CONCORD OF AYE
MCCARTY?
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
TING AYE.
THERE'S WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS -- WE MEMBERS
WERE STILL WAITING FOR TWO
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS BUT WE WILL
CLOSE THIS COMMITTEE HEARING --
BUT THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES OF AND
ALSO DOES NOT SHOW UP -- SO IF
YOU CAN KINDLY WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES.
AND THEN -- EGG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A MOVE ON THEN TO
ADDITIONAL -- BILLS THAT ALSO
NEEDS TO BE VOTED ON SO OTHERS
GOING FILE ITEM FILE ORDER THANK
YOU OF FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS AB [inaudible]
FIVE FOUR FIVE BY LOW.
WE NEED A MOTION.
IT IS A MOTION AND A SECOND CA
RESEARCHER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE MOTIONS DO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
AYE LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHIU CUNNINGHAM
DOLLY DALY AYE EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON?
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
HI COME UNDER DOES COME WITH A
DOVE I MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
OBERNOLTE ABILITY AYE TING TING
I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS A. B. SIX
ONE THREE BY LOW.
WE NEED A MOTION.
MOTION A SECOND TWENTY SIX TRADE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY SIX
THIRTEEN MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW THE I. BROWN
BLOOM.
THEN I CHEN.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
DAWALY NOW EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
FONG.
FUNG NOW GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GORE I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
COMMENTED UFFE.
I'M GONNA AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE AROUND YOU KNOW TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
WHICH IS AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT BY
IT LOW.
AND IF ALLEN ARE.
TEN YEAH WE NEED A MOTION.
THE LESSONS I CAN CONSIDER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS TO COMMITTEE ON HEALTH LOW
AYE LOW AYE BRO.
BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM DALY?
AYE EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
PHONE NINE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GRAY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
I CONCORD I'VE COME A DEADLINE
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN OBERNOLTE REALTY I
TING TING AYE.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AGAIN MEMBERS OF WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS -- BUT OUT OF HERE WE GO
PERFECT.
SO WE'LL GO TO FILE AND NUMBER --
TWELVE WHICH IS AB TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SUMMER COOLEY MR COOLEY
THIS HAS. TO PASS RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD MORNING THIS AYE PLEASE
RENT A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT THIS OF
WRITER CANIBUS DELIVERS AND
TRACK AND TRACE.
OF REQUIRES A MINIMUM.
IT SAYS RULES RELATED TO TRACK
AND TRACE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO ESTABLISH.
IN A CANNABIS THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION CHAIN.
REQUIRES OF THEM THE INFORMATION
TO CONTAIN THE LICENSE TO
RECEIVE THE PRODUCT TRANSACTION
A CULTIVATOR.
OF IT.
CLOSE JUST A LITTLE GAP IN THE
REGULATORY PROGRAM PROVIDES
IMPORTANT INFORMATION LOCALS
ACOSTA RIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS MAN MOTION A
SECOND ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COMMIT THE MY PHONE NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
AS AND AS ADDRESSES A LIST OF
MARKET ACTIVITY WE DO APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND I
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI CAITLYN O'NEILL EASE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
IT'S VERY MUCH EDITION WITH THIS
IS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING AS CHAIR MEMBERS CHAO'S
HURRIEDLY COMPANY CITIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE'S IN OPPOSITION SEEN A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
MEMBERS SEE NO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IS AN EMOTION A SECOND.
MEDICAL IF YOU WISH TO CLOSE
QUESTION I VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE CITY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS
TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW
THOUGH I BROWN.
BRIAN BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN.
CHAN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM DOLLY DON'T AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GOOD I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I COME OVER TO US COMING OR
NOT HI MCCARTY?
MEDINA MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
BASICALLY THAT HAS TWELVE MOSTLY
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
VERY GOOD I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WELL MY MOM FELL FIVE
FINAL ITEM WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DONE OF THIS
ENJOYS TO PASS RECOGNITION ON
BOTH SIDES AL THESE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY IS YOUR
RECOMMENDATION THAT I BE BRIEF
MR CARE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO RESENT
HOWEVER YOU WISH THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM.
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WILL UPDATE
THE LIMITS ON LOANS THAT
MORTGAGE BROKERS CAN SECURE FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
PROJECTS. TO MORE ACCURATELY
REFLECT CURRENT PROPERTY VALUES
AND DEVELOPMENT COSTS THIS BILL
IS ABOUT MORE HOUSING MISTER
CHAIR.
MORTGAGE BROKERS ARE LICENSED
REAL ESTATE BROKERS WHO ARRANGE
LOANS USING REAL PROPERTY AS
COLLATERAL.
THESE BROKERS BRING TOGETHER
PRIVATE LENDERS AND BORROWERS TO
PROVIDE FINANCING TO PURCHASE A
WIDE ARRAY OF PROPERTIES
INCLUDING SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES.
APARTMENT COMPLEXES AND MANY
OTHERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND THREE TO ACCOUNT
FOR CHANGES IN THE
INTERPRETATION OF EXISTING LOAN
RULES THE LEGISLATURE CREATED A
NEW LONG CATEGORY FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
LOANS.
THIS NEW CATEGORY WOULD ALLOW
BROKERS TO FACTOR IN THE ADDED
PROPERTY VALUE FOR CONSTRUCTION
AND REPAIRS WHEN DETERMINING.
THE SIZE OF A LOAN. TO PREVENT
ABUSE OF THIS FLEXIBILITY
SEVERAL NEW RULES WERE CREATED
TO PROTECT BORROWERS AND LENDERS
FROM ADDITIONAL RISK. ONE OF
THESE ROLES WAS A TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR LIMIT ON THE SIZE
ALONE THAT'S THE LIMIT TODAY.
THIS LIMIT HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE IT WENT INTO EFFECT
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
SINCE THEN INFLATION AND RISING
PROPERTY VALUES HAVE
DRAMATICALLY DRAWING UP THE COST
OF NEW DEVELOPMENTS AROSE
REHABILITATION COSTS.
IN A TIME WHEN NEW HOUSING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING
DEL DEVELOPERS WITH MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO FINANCE ARE
PROJECTS.
NOT FEWER THIS BILL DOES THAT AB --
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MY
CONSTRUCTION AND REHABILITATION
LOANS A VIABLE OPTION FOR
DEVELOPERS AGAIN BY INCREASING
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD TO FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
MICHAEL ARNOLD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER ON UP
TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE AUTHOR HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB OF PRESENTING THE BILL
THE ANALYSIS IS EXCELLENT I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
ARNOLD ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND SECOND
SUMMER DONE TO WISH TO CLOSE.
AS FOR A NIGHT OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THE SECRETARY JAN THIS IS ON
ASSEMBLY BILL.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR FILE IN
MY THIRTEEN IN MOTION AND A
SECOND FOLLOWED UNDER THIRTEEN
PLEASE.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS
TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS LOW LOW
AYE BRO BROUGH AYE BLOOM.
MY CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DOLLY DALY AYE
EGGMAN.
WHEN I FONG FONG AYE GIPSON?
GLORIA.
I GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I IRWIN -- AND I CONCORD
I'VE.
COME A GOOD UP LIVE MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I TING.
CHILL. TO AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN BOTH
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE BACK INTO
ORDERS AND LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
MOST EVERYONE ELSE HERE -- SO
WE'LL START OFF WITH CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AB FOR NINETY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASS EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY MOTIONS YOU PASTA
PREPARATIONS AB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT MOTIONS DISASTER
PREPARATIONS AB EIGHT NINE SIX
MOTIONS DEPOSITOR PREPARATIONS.
AB FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE MOTION IS
TO PASS BRO.
HI JOHN.
CHEN I CHILL. TWO I CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
TING. SIXTEEN WHAT'S THE
CONSENSUS.
PASSED WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO MEMBERS CAN FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM OR TWO WHICH IS A
BEFORE.
FOR ANY FOUR ZERO FOUR MOTIONS
YOU PASSED APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO AYE CHAN CHAN I CHILL TO AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
TING [inaudible] SIX SIXTEEN
BOTH THE BILL IS OUT.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM OR
FOR WHICH IS AB.
FIVE FORTY FIVE AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE MOTIONS DEPARTURE
PREPARATIONS BRO.
BRO I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
MCCARTY MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN. SIXTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT FOR ME ON TO FILE AND A FIVE
AB.
SIX ONE THREE SB SIX THIRTEEN
MOTIONS TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
BRO.
BRO NOW CHEN.
CHEN NOT VOTING.
JILL. TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOW.
GIPSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN. FOR NOW MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN A
SUMMER DALY FATHER. SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY BRO.
BROUGH AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I GLORIA.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MULLIN TING. FIFTY VOTE THE BILL
IS OUT OF THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS IF I REMEMBER
NUMBER EIGHT AB SIX NINETY IS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AB SIX NINE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BRO.
BRO I CHEN.
CHEN I CHILL TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GRAYSON.
REASON I HOLDEN.
I MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
TING [inaudible] SIXTEEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT WITH A MOVE ON
TO FILE AN AMER. TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH BROKE.
BROWN NOT VOTING.
CHILL. TO AYE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I EGGMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
ONE FIFTH -- FIFTEEN THAT
ABILITY OUT MOWING DOWN THEN
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT AB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO POSSIBLE
RATIONS. TO TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I GIPSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING. SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS TO FOSTER
APPROPRIATIONS FONG [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
TING.
ON AYE FONG AYE. SEVENTEEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT AND THE FINAL
ITEM FILE NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE BY SUMMER DINA.
ANY SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTIONS
YOU PASSED APPROPRIATIONS BLOW
FOR BLOW.
GEN.
GEN I TO TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
MY HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
AT NIGHT IN NINETEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT A MEMBERS WILL --
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES AND THEN
AND FOR ADD ONS -- IN THE
MEANTIME.
NUMBER TWO YOU WISH TO MR
MCCARTY WAS TO SEE THEM
MICROPHONE YOUR YOUR YES PLEASE
ADD ME ON TO ALL THE OTHER
MEASURES AS AND I MISTER MISTER
MEDINA.
AND IF MR MEDINA GOOD DO THE
SAME YES THE SAME IS AND AYE
AYES ON ON ALL MEASURES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AS MISTER MISS MELODY WAS TO DO
THE SAME.
I'M GONNA PULL MCCARTY AND SAY I
ON EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THEN -- COMEY SERVED IT WILL
JUST GO THROUGH THE THE ITEMS
AGAIN AND A NOTE TO THE THE
VARIOUS MEMBERS WHO HAVE --
VOTED.
CONSENT CALENDAR AB ONE EIGHTY
SIX MOTIONS YOU PASS EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY MOTIONS YOU MUST
APPROPRIATIONS AB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT MOTIONS YOU PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS AB NINETY SIX
MOTIONS TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE
MOTIONS DUCASSE.
MCCARTY MCCARTY THAN I MEDINA
MEDINA AND I MULLIN MULLIN
TONIGHT [inaudible] TWENTY ZERO
THAT IS THE TOP DID.
IF YOU FOR A FOR MOTIONS YOU
PAST APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY
MCCARTY'S AND I MEDINA MEDINA I
AM MULLIN MULLIN TONIGHT. NINETY
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS GIPSON
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA'S AYE MULLIN MALLS AYE.
NINETEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
SB SIX THIRTEEN MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN AYE.
TALK TO SIX THE BILL WITHOUT.
AB SIXTY SEVEN MOTIONS YOU
PASSED COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HIGH MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TING. EIGHTEEN TWO ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT. EIGHTY SIX NINETY
MOTIONS YOU PAST APPROPRIATIONS
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN MULLIN AYE
TING. NINETY ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
AB EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH [inaudible]
GIPSON.
MEDINA MEDINA MY MULLIN MORE
THAN I SEVENTEENTH ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS GIPSON.
MEDINA MEDINA AS AN ACTING.
EIGHTEEN IS THERE THE BILL'S OUT.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS
DISASTER PREPARATIONS GIPSON
MEDINA MEDINA AYE TING. EIGHTEEN
IS THERE THE BILL'S OUT.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE GIPSON.
NINETEEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
WE JUST.
WE WILL BE OUT OF THAT.
WELL THIS IS MIKE GIPSON AND
LIKE A WATCH GIPSON.
YES.
I KNOW YES OKAY OPEN UP THERE
OVER THE WEEKEND MISSING.
I AM I ON EVERYTHING SO YOU CAN
FOR THAT PERFECT.
THANK YOU.
CONTENT COME UNDER TING TING AYE.
JOHN QUICKLY AND TWENTY ZERO AB
FOR A FOR TING TING AYE
[inaudible] TWENTY ZERO AB FIVE
FORTY FIVE TING [inaudible]
NINETEEN ZERO EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN MOTIONS YOU MUST COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY TING TING AYE
[inaudible] NINETEEN ZERO SB
SIX NINETY MOTIONS YOU PASTOR
PREPARATIONS TING TING AYE
[inaudible] TWENTY ZERO AB
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS TING TING
AYE [inaudible] NINETEEN ZERO AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MOTIONS YOU
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS TING TING
AYE [inaudible] NINETEEN ZERO AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY ONE MOTIONS YOU
MUST APPROPRIATIONS TING TING
AYE. NINETEEN TWO ZERO AND THAT
IS IT WE ARE JOINED